[Music]
hi i'm casey and i leaving was Hollywood
and why Big Brother why not
Big Brother I mean I watch the show on
my phone I love it and it's just like a
personal challenge experience and it's
just I got selected so it's gonna be an
amazing summer and I can no wait are you
a super fan of the show or just kind of
like a casual viewer well the thing is
like it seems because of my job I'm
always like outside the country all the
summer so I'm know I'm not able to rely
follow it but every time like I will
come back I will always like watch it
for the last like five years so yeah I
watch it I'm a fine binge watch it yes I
gotta sleep like you know like in the
HOH competition you're a dancer right
yeah I do dancing event productions
entertainment just that in vitamin yeah
that's quite the thing to leave to go do
Big Brother I know right I know it's
like I said it's my first summer here in
the United States in like four five
years so you know like it's just a
little bit of everything I get and we
dance we like crazy office and stop or
we will put together parties or we're
like the spirit of the party yeah
everyone gets drunk yeah and that's not
me
now you get to bring that into the Big
Brother house it's ugly it's gonna be
fun it's gonna be a fun summer for sure
do you have a favorite past Big Brother
contestant I have people who I am and I
think they did like an amazing game but
um but I don't like a favorite okay so I
Derek for instance I think you did an
amazing you know like the like you know
yeah if you had to pick somebody to kind
of play like them but it'd be Derek or
somebody else would it be Derek with a
little bit more like of like personality
okay yeah I think it's hard for you to
hide your personality it's gonna be hard
I mean it's my is what I want to do at
the beginning just like be like very
like quiet and try not to be a target
it's gonna be hard but to watch me I'm
gonna do it is there any thing you're
gonna keep secret from your fellow
houseguests at first yes the fact that I
asked
actually work in this environment has
given me the experience to like go and I
live in like different countries for
like a period of time and like we like
20 25 people from like also different
countries different languages so I've
seen so many things and I've experienced
so many things but they have no idea
that I actually like already know about
it and hear what MTV so they actually
and over there we we went and so I've
seen like crazy it's being something
like girls like banging each other and I
I I've seen as you've seen some things
yes and they don't need to know that I
have that experience they don't need to
know that I come from like a background
when every single so much that's what
I've been doing
being a Big Brother house but in some
other countries with different people I
didn't even speak the same language so I
think that's something to my advantage
yeah so you've lived a crazy summer
after crazy summers yeah this is gonna
be easy for you hopefully I don't want
to fake that cuz anyone that I ain't
gonna be easy that I'm gonna be affairs
more like oh is this well it is Big
Brother 20 he's a big deal that it is a
big deal and I'm very worried about that
because I know those executive producers
are gonna come up with something because
20 is a very crazy number I mean like
hello like you don't celebrate like
super crazy you're 27 this is amazing
but crazy or 25 Saudis or you know those
numbers that Adam is there a twist you
would love to see happen yeah you see
the winner shortest season of Big
Brother mmm
[Laughter]
like I don't know I don't know if
anything is that I would like probably
better with me it would be nice oh it's
just anything that benefits you yes they
might bring some veteran players back no
please no Paul Paul stay home you know I
love you but we don't want you there if
they did bring back somebody who had
played the game before who would you
like to see play
I don't really know like you know I just
don't want any III mean I wouldn't mind
a bet there was just gonna like make
them feel what I mean I'm gonna make
them feel welcome and you know and I
play baking with them but you know but
at the same time I'm scared that it
could turn out like to be like someone
like Paul for instance connects like so
that baby 19 and that was the Paul show
yeah and I don't want that to happen
this season so like I don't know I don't
know what I will do let's see when I get
to the house this game can get pretty
vicious how vicious will you get in that
house like I said I'm gonna go with the
flow
I'm not gonna let things like get at me
I have a little spear ins with starvin
thing I'm gonna have to have like an
amazing personality I'm gonna enjoy my
summit I want people then the house also
enjoy my summer I don't wanna be the
mean one
and they want like you know like like
crazy no no I'm gonna be the fun one I
wanna be a fun to watch and when you sit
on that TV and you see me like right
there with the consensus and then great
things you're like oh this is so much
fun and relax and it slightly like like
like like something that you would enjoy
so I want anything you this summer
hey summer for every party all the time
party all the time I'm tired but I'm
trying do you think your houseguests
will underestimate you because of you
your size yes and that's what I wanted
to do I wanted to think that I'm like
this small guy like super adorable with
a nice personality oh I want to bring
him with me till the end and that's
someone and that's when you'll stab him
in the back I don't know if I'm gonna
stop them but I know what that is if
he's gonna help me to get in their house
and stuff and like kill them with
kindness I've seen that I said that very
like 20,000 hours
what about show manses are you looking
for love this summer nope
I don't want to say no no no because
every time someone say no she omens -
omens are the first one who always
getting jealous but I'm representing
LGBTQ I've never seen two LGBT members
in NSC Sun and I don't think that is
just gonna be a showmance to be honest
so I'm not really worried about it okay
yeah who knows though season 20 could
mix things up okay this shows a way of
exposing secrets about people's lives
is there anything you're nervous being
revealed about you no really no I'm very
social very talkative my friends don't
know anything about me
you know it's just not really like I
feel like they're just gonna like hear
me saying the same thing that always
hurt but justin.tv
like like hide everything besides the
fact that I that I'm very familiar with
all this in that craziness besides that
I don't think nothing else to hide no
nothing to confess to you right now no
like something I'm gay hi I'm gay
yes oh wow I mean no no now they don't
speak English so I don't care you are
hopefully gonna be in that house for
three whole months what are you gonna
miss most about the outside world
I already mean I you know I am NOT very
missing like being able to be outside
but having like a social life different
from that how am i phone we're so
dependent on our phones that we don't
realize you can just do it put your
phone away for like 24 hours and see if
you can do it it's really hard like
sometimes I even want to share like the
weather how tall is it and I go and I
check my pockets all the time and I'm
like oh did I lost it I don't know I
just haven't had if I Wow
yeah it's like crazy yeah disconnection
yeah no we're really really really into
that it's just crazy and I didn't really
realize how how much I needed my phone
to like it lately
it drives you kinda crazy it's like you
have to adjust your mind to it yes crazy
yeah on the flip side is there anything
that you're excited to not have to deal
with for three months a person a thing
in your life mmm I don't know um I'm not
paying rent not really like you know
it's just three months I'm gonna miss my
close friends and stuff so having my
freedom III respect freedom a lot you
know so it's just gonna be hard to be
like in that thing but I'm gonna try to
the most out of it hey hopefully you get
$500,000 and I'll make the most of it
thank you why are you gonna win big
brother because I think I I have a good
chance to win because I have like I mean
it's a it's a it's a game of all like
about your social like um skills and
about your physical skills and I think I
have what I can be social you see like
we're having a conversation right yes
all right hey girl and also I feel like
the athletic part the physical I can
like I think I can do some of those
competitions and maybe I win then I
think it's a good combination and if I'm
smart about it I have a good chance to
win for sure I want to compete there it
is I like a good attitude positive
energy like you're gonna kill it thank
you have a good summer
[Music]